le cinéma donc maintenant avec le
festival de cannes une très bonne cuvée
semble-t-il cette année puisque au
programme on remarque le nom des plus
grands réalisateurs mondiaux nous
retrouvons maintenant sur place franche
roche au soleil de cannes bonjour france
bonjour hervé j'arrive avec un très bon
film en effet jusqu'à maintenant le
festival avait fait chanter danser il
avait fait penser et bien maintenant il
fait pleurer en effet ce matin à la
projection pour les critiques on a vu
des critiques masculin très cordiale
très coriace sortir en larmes ce film
ses carreaux papa de dino risi avec
vittorio gassman je les ai rencontrés
avant qu'ils se rendent à leur
conférence de presse
je sais qu'on me presque toujours dans
notre cinéma sûrement dans le cinéma de
dino risi il ya toujours un mélange et
des éléments divers delà de la ville
rire elle est le plus est l effet la
base du film le thème fondamental c'est
un thème dramatique c'est une une
relation entre un père un fils qui est
un peu symbolique du tout sur les
relations entre les pères et les fils
dans l'histoire et surtout dans notre
histoire contemporaine
spécifiquement à l'italie qui est une
histoire difficile des rapports de temps
en temps deviennent fragiles comme par
le tas pour ce film vous avez travaillé
avec votre fils ce que c'est comme avec
de travailler avec son fils
là le président mon fils était enfin
c'était j'ai besoin de quelqu'un en jeu
ok qui juge le côté jeu inquiète dans le
film parce que c'est un rapport entre un
père un fils et alors là qui me suis
servi de lui puisque
il est mon fils mes éléments critiques
les plus serrées je pense que les jeunes
ce qui les gêne nous reproche le plus
c'est d'avoir été trop distrait pour la
construction de noms de nos mythes et de
nos carrières personnelles et ça c'est
la grande responsabilité que nous
sentons de temps en temps en étant vieux
et père avait donc les questions de
terrorisme est-ce que vous n'avez pas
peur que vous envoient des bombes
non parce que il en profite et jusqu'à
ce moment général et israël sont assez
rapide dans ma décision
vous savez on vit une situation
tellement dramatique et confuse que on
est forcé de développer une espèce de
le fatalisme de malaise chronique de
laquelle on cherche de souris avec ses
propres moyens l'un de ses moyens c'est
l'expressivité c'est-à-dire d'exprimer
ses tourments ses souffrances ses doutes
ses peurs est cependant plus un film sur
le terrorisme
c'est plus tranquille sur la famille sur
la peur qui écrit un cinquième qui est
un peu ce sentiment qui vit avec nous en
italie jeu même si vous voyez un pays
qui a l'air d'être très très bien vrai
c'est que l'italien deux faces vraiment
parce violente
le visage inquiet
comme ça et ce n'est les
visage désir de vivre sympathie
la bombe et la pizza la bombe et la
pizza oui c'est un peu comme ça